では よろしくお願いします
後ろに聞こえますかね
では 最初に決まっているこの法句経の偈の説明をいたします
今日は9番目と10番目です
アニッカサーヴォー カーサーワン ヨワッタン パリダヘッサティ アペトー ダンマ サッチーナ ナソー カーサーワ マルハティ
これまあ9番目ですね
それから意味を見てください
最初の言葉はアニッカサーヴォーという言葉なんで
できるだけ日本 パーリのローマ字の方を見て意味を聞いた方がいいかもしれません
それからまとめの日本語訳は別にございますので
それはそれから考えた方がやりやすいです
これ同じ言葉でちょっとしたこの
何と言いますか 同じ言葉で違う意味が入っている
似ている言葉で作っている偈なんですよ
日本語でもたくさんありますからね
発音も同じですけど 全く意味が違うような感じのね
そういう風な感じの言葉で
ですから アニッカサーワ
カーサーワという 2つの言葉をよく使っています
1番目の言葉はアニッカサーヴォー
アっていうのは否定形で
ニっていうのはまたないという意味で使う言葉なんですね
それでカーサーワ その1番目のカーサーワっていうのは汚れという意味なんですね
それでニッカサーワになっちゃうと汚れがないっていうことになるんですね
汚れから離れるという意味なんです
ないよりもニるという言葉ですから
ニが入っちゃうと何かから離れている
それから汚れから離れているということ
ア入れちゃうと否定形で
ということは汚れから離れてない
では汚れって何なのかと
当然ブッダの言葉だから
服の汚れのことを言っているわけじゃないし
自然の汚れのことも言っているわけじゃないんですね
この場合は心の汚れということを言っているんですね
そこで心の汚れから離れてなくて
アニッカサーワでいながらカーサーワを着ていると
2番目のカーサーワも褐色
黄褐色という訳だと思いますけど
で まあ色のことなんですね
で カーサーワというのは日本語で袈裟という言葉がございますね
その日本語の袈裟はこのパーリサンスクリット語でこのカーシャーヤ
カーサーワという言葉から出ているんです
それで袈裟といえば 何か日本語
日本でお坊さんたちがすごく変な顔をするんですね
これ何なのか これは袈裟ですと
あれ？と言うんですね
だから袈裟っていうのはこれじゃないみたいですね
何か別なものだと思っている場合もありますけど
まああの 袈裟というのは
まあただ出家が着る衣のことで
特別に四角く作るものやらね
首にかける 何でしたっけ？ネクタイみたいなベルトとかね
そういうおしゃれなものではありません
ただ服ということでね
出家の服っていう意味なんです
日本の文化になってくると
各物に別々な言葉をつけてるんだから
そうやって驚いたりするのもそれは無理のない話ですけど
一応例えば私たち着ている服はまあカーサーワ
あるいは袈裟というものなんですね
なんでこのカーサーワを黄褐色の衣と言うんでしょうかというと
この昔今もそうなんですけど
やっぱり服っていうのはおしゃれなんですよ
普通の人々にとっては
自分をよく見せるために使うものなんですね
その時点からも仏教はちょっと人間がいつでも道から脱出しているのではないかと
道からちょっと離れるとかなり問題が起きるんですよ
もともと何で服が来たんですかというと
地球上でいた他の生命と比べると
人間というのはかなり弱い
ものすごく弱い動物なんですよ
ちょっとしたことで体が壊れて死んでしまいます
その代わりに ヘビに毒があるような感じに
人間にもちょっとした武器が自然についているんですよ
馬にが 馬に早く走れる足があるし
ゾウさんだったらものすごい巨体で
それで生きていられます
そうやって地球にいる生命には生き続けるために何か武器がついているんです
それが本当は餌を取って
敵から身を守って生活するためのついている武器なんですよ
それは仏教から言えば
自分の過去の業から出ているもので
神様が与えてくれたものというわけじゃないんです
で それで人間が弱いんだけど
人間に知識という脳が働くんですね
他の動物と比べると 結構脳が働くんですね
これが人間の武器ですよ
ヘビの毒と同じことなんですね
だから人間というのは体が寒いし
暑いし もう病気になる
それでいろいろものを体につけてみることにしたんです
それが服の始まりで 暑さ
寒さを避けるために 体を守るためにということ
それ基本から それから人間が脱線するんですね
脱線して 自分をよく見せるために
かっこつけるために使うことになる
それからさらに脱線して
もう何ですかね 自分が持ってないものまで
もう服で世間に見せてやろうではないかと思ったりする
例えばお金がないんですけど
もうなんとかそれなりの服なんか着て外で街を歩いていると
もう誰もわかりません
もしかするとお金の余裕がある人ではないかと
もう思わせてしまうことはいたも簡単にできるんですね
それで問題が起きるんですよ
道から脱線しちゃうと
もうきりがなく それ変わって変わっていくんですよ
それで色やらデザインやら形やら
あらゆるものが成り立ってきます
どこまで発展するかというと
体を守る服が体を守れなくなるない
ただ見せるだけのことまでに発展していくんですね
で 体を隠すんじゃなくて
どうやって体を外へ出すかと
そういうところまで 考えたりする
その世界でいろんなトラブルやら精神的な問題やら
いろんなものは出てくる
そこで 出家する人々にお釈迦様はその問題を厳密に言ってるんですね
道から脱線してはいけませんと
服を着る基本的な意味
それは決して忘れてはいけませんと
だから私たちは 出家の人々は
朝も昼も夜も 必ずしも服を着る基本的な意味を思い浮かばさなくちゃいけないんです
必ずしも 何のために服を着るんですかと
これ毎日思い浮かばないとすぐ忘れるんです
それ思い浮かばないと
すぐかっこつけるために服を着ることになっちゃうんです
それは服を着る基本的な目的っていうのは
寒さと暑さを避けることと
それからいろいろね 虫やらね
蛇やらね そういう動物に噛まれたり
体が壊れたり 病気になったりするんだから
そういうものから体を守るために
それからきつい風が吹いてくると
きつい日差しがあると
もう体が壊れちゃいますね
その場合も そういうふうなものから体を守るために
それから体の恥ずかしいところは
だいたい体隠しておいた方がいいというふうには思ってるんですね
体はもう全部裸で出していくっていうことは
あまり文化的に品格のいいことではないと
だからもう全部体を隠しておくと
そうやって体を隠しておく
なぜ体隠しておくかって
それは人間だけの世界で
もう人間っていうのはすごく体に対して欲を作るんですね
だから人間が人間の体を見ると
すごい心が欲を出しちゃって
頭がおかしくなるんです
自然に欲が出たっても
そんなにおかしくなるわけじゃないんだけど
必ずしも人の体を見ると
もう頭がおかしくなるんですよ
精神的に異常現象を起こしちゃうんですね
これは動物はやりません
動物はもうずっと生まれつき裸だから
まああまり同じ仲間を見てね
ちょっともうおかしいことをしたっていうことはありえないんですよ
何でしたっけ？今よく流行ってることはストーカーやったとかね
もう一つありますね セクハラではなくて
体を触ったりすることを何て言いますか
あ 痴漢とかね そういう異常現象を起こしちゃうんですね
精神的に病気になる人は結構いますよ
だから これが人間の思考の脳の問題で
すごい困ったもんですよ
結局知識はね ヘビには毒があって
全然問題を起こしてないし
平和で生活しているしね
人間もそういうふうに知識使えばいいのに
いつでもなんか運転間違うんですね
間違って大事な知識なのに
それが使い方間違って精神的に病気になってしまうとこまでもあります
大体はもうほとんど人々は精神的な何か問題持ってますよ
何も精神的な問題を持ってない人っていうのはありえない
そこまで精神的にちょっと機能がそれほどスムーズに動いているわけじゃないんです
ですから かなり脆い 人間の知識は
だからすごく気をつけなくちゃいけない
そういうことで 服着ることでも一生一回思い出しただけではダメなんですよ
だから出家の場合は 朝も夜も何のためにこの服を着ているんでしょうかと
それはずっと思い出すんです
だから思い出すためにいろいろ文章
いろいろではなくて 決まってる一つの文章ですが
文章までできているんです
それぐらい我々は服に対して間違いは起こしちゃいます
別に 在家の普通の人々をおしゃれして何が悪いのかということではないんですよ
おしゃれして決して悪くはないんだけど
どこまでやるのかということは問題なんですよ
それがわからないんですよ
いつでもその問題 社会で見えますよ
金儲けることは決して悪くないんですよ
食べていられませんから
でもしかし脱線しているんですね
どこまで儲かるのかというと
あるいはどんな手段で金儲かるかという
これはわからない だから手段どうでもいい
いくら儲かってもいい
とにかく金儲けましょうという風に
もう脱線状態になっちゃうんです
あるいは照準不可能な状態になるんです
自分の だから社会に見える現象はそれなんですよ
だからそれはすごい問題なんですよ
力ある人々は儲けて儲けて儲けていくのはいいんだけど
それで地球のバランスが崩れて崩れて崩れていく
食べられない人々はいっぱい出てくる
この儲かる人々によってものすごく搾取される人々というのがたくさん出てくる
不公平なことにあって
悔しい思いをする人々はたくさん出てくる
そうすると その人々は社会の秩序を壊す
あまりにも不公平なことに
もう毎日のように生まれつき遭っているんだからね
例えばパレスチナ人には国がない
追い出されている そういう風ないろいろ問題が出てくると
もうそういう人々が自然に社会の秩序を壊してしまうんですよ
そうなるとどうなるかというと
せっかくお金儲かっている人々にも
24時間すごい怯えて生活するしか
震えて怯えて生活しなくちゃいけないんですよ
それだったらいくら財産があっても何の意味もないんですよ
気持ちよく 楽しく 自分を得た財産を喜べないんですよ
例えば 豪華な車買っても
外は見えないように全部隠しておくんですね
だから箱の中で目を目隠しして
時々人々は誘拐するときはね
目隠しして車に乗せられて
それってそんな感じですよ
すごい豊かな人々は 外は見えません
だから何やってるんでしょうかということになるんですよ
だから脱線しちゃうと
もうどちらでも失敗する
例えば金儲かることで儲けて儲けて
とにかく世界地球のバランスまで崩した人と
それにやられて貧しくて貧しくて食べるものもない人々
どちらでも生きていられない状態なんですね
かわいそうに どちらでもすごい不幸なんですよ
だから脱線することっていうのは
ちょっと気をつけて考えた方がいいとは思います
そんな簡単なものではない
だからいくらか気をつけておしゃれしてもよろしいし
美味しいものを食べてもよろしいし
それは決して悪いものではありません
しかし お釈迦様が言うのは
脱線することだけは気をつけなくてはいけないんですね
でないと平和で豊かで生きることは
できなくなる そういうわけだから
このモデルとしてこの出家組織を作っているんですよ
出家組織っていうのは社会の人々に対するモデルなんですね
だからもうやらん方がいいんですよ
出家なんかは これ 模範的な生き方っていうのは人間にできるものじゃないんだから
だからもう大変なことなんです
食べる時でも 喋る時でも
服を着る時でも 何から何まで決まりものすごいたくさんありまして
その中で生活しなくちゃいけない
そのあらゆる決まりがなぜできているかというと
やっぱりこの道から道といったら人間の生きる道ですよ
そこから脱線しないようにと
そこで出家がモデルだから
基本的なところで止まっている
どうしても必要なところで止まっている
在家の形々はそれよりプラスアルファでいろいろ楽しがってもいいんだけど
どこまででもやるのをやりますということはやめた方がいいんです
そこでいくらかこの合わせちゃうと
在家と出家の生活をね
一緒に生活してみると
在家の人々はまあほどほどのところでストップするんですよ
人生楽しむこと 贅沢をすることは
もうギリギリまでやるんじゃなくて
ほどほどのところで 危険のないところでストップするんです
だから そういう理想的な社会なんですよ
お釈迦様が作ろうとしたのは
だから出家もいて 在家もいる
どちらでも必要なんです
出家がいらんと言ったら
それでもう全部壊れてしまいます
あるいは社会のみんな出家しちゃうと
それでも全部壊れてしまいます
だから互いに あの 何て言いますか
協力し合って生きていられるように
出家は経済活動をしないことにする
そうすると出家は在家に頼って生活しなくちゃいけない
しかし 在家の人々にはもう忙しいんだから
何でも自分で判断したり決めたりすることは決して無理
そっち人生失敗したりする
だから誰かが自分をガイドしてリードして
あの先生役 指導者役をやらなくちゃいかない
それが出家がちゃんとやってあげる
そういうわけで 在家の人々にも出家はないと生活できない状態
出家の人々にも在家がないと生活できない状態や互いに協力し合っている状態が成り立っているんです
だから変なシステムを作ったわけじゃないんです
ものすごい知恵で考えたシステムなんです
だから威張ることはどちらでも禁止
在家の人々も私にあれがあるとこれがあるんだと威張っちゃうとお釈迦様はすごい貶しちゃうんです
バカが喜ぶんやと そんなことで
お金がある 子供がいるとかね
ひどい目に遭いますよ
そのうち 出家の人々にも決して高慢張ったりしちゃうと
もうもう何て言いますか
もう えっと 何か例えがあります
あの火葬場で捨てた焼けた薪みたいなもんだと
火葬場で遺体を焼く時は薪を使うんですよ
そこでもう焼いた薪なんかはまたもうちょっと残っていたっても
誰も使おうと思わないんですね
気持ち悪いと それでもって拾ってご飯炊くこととか誰も思わない
遺体を焼くために使ったものだからね
そんなもんだよと あなた方も高慢張ったりすると
人生は価値がないんだと
ですから そういう高慢があったり
威張ったりすることはどちらでも禁止と
それでこのうまく平和な世界を作ること
お釈迦様は一応モデルを作って涅槃に入ったんです
やり残した仕事は何一つない
お釈迦様は全部やって終わったんです
後の人間がそれを正しくやるかやらないかはそちらの問題で
足らない教えっていうのはないんだよ
全部もう実践までさせてモデルまで作って
涅槃に入りましたからね
それでカーサーワンという話にまた戻りますが
この服の基本的なところで
一応何か布やら拾って
それは何ていうのは抜いて
適当な大きさにして 普通の服だから
まあいろいろカラーが色が入ってるんですよ
だからそうすると 見た目は良くない
いろんなデザインのいろんな色の服をつなげてつなげて
それで衣を着ろうと思っちゃうと
見る人にとってはちょっと気持ち悪い
しかし おしゃれもしてはいけない
それで お釈迦様はこの褐色の色に染めなさいと言われているんです
その色に色を染めることは
だいたい自然の中だったら難しくない
化学の染料というんですか
そういうものっていうのはなくてもできますよ
そこら辺にあるこの硬いこの木の根元やらね
硬い木の真ん中 葉っぱ
そういうものとか またいろいろ葉っぱとかね
落ち葉とかね そういうものを集めて煮出しちゃうと
その色なんです 面白いことに同じ色でできますよ
ある一つの植物だけ使うと
またある決まっている色になるんだけど
一つの植物じゃなくて
いくつかあっちこっちあるものを適当に集めて
煮出すんです それでも国と関係なく
植物に関係なく ほぼ同じ色で出来上がっちゃうんです
服は それで元の色は見事に消えるんです
元の色というのは青いやら赤やら
それすごい難しいんですよ
青い色出すこと 特に日本人よく知ってますからね
あれ 何染め 藍染めっていうのはね
あれかなり技術は必要な難しいんですよ
それから綺麗な青を出そうと思っちゃうと
綺麗な黄色い色を出そうと思っちゃうと
結構技術必要なんです
技術必要ない その色は簡単に落ちるんです
そうやって決まっておしゃれ感覚で作る色っていうのは簡単に落ちる
でも何もなく いい加減あっちこっちあるものは全部揃って煮出して衣を色付けちゃうと
これはそう簡単には色が落ちません
元の色は消える 元は青であっても
それは消えちゃう そんな感じで
ですから この釈尊はこの純粋な色は禁止しているんです
純粋な色っていうのは
この原色 いくつか原色といったら３つですけど
まあ一応はっきり我々が色で認識するものはいくつかあります
赤とかね 青とか で 黒いブラックとかね
ホワイト 白い で まあその系統でいくつか出てきますね
何々色とはっきり言えるものはね
それは使ってはいけません
ということになっていて
褐色色なんですね いわゆるオレンジとブラウンの間の色なんですね
それはいくら濃い色でも構いません
中間的な色 混ぜてる色なんですよ
青と緑は使いません もう決まって使いません
白いはどうしてもないし
いろいろいわゆるはっきりする色は使わないってことになっているんです
それは衣のことで それでどうなるかというと
この便利になるんですね
技術なくてもまとめな服を作られる
まとめに染められる 何十年もこの服を染めるために修行しなくちゃいかないという俗世間の問題はないんです
見ただけで はい わかりますということになるんです
それですごく楽ですよ
それから次に言うのは
アニッカサーウォカーサーワン
これカーサーワカーサーワという同じ言葉で
一つは汚れ 一つは袈裟という意味で言葉似ているんですけど
アニッカサーウォのカーサーワという言葉の意味は汚れ
2番目のカーサーワの意味は袈裟ですね
或る黄褐色色の服という意味なんですね
次にヨワッタンパリダヘッセティヨ
誰かがワッタン服をパリダヘッセティ纏っているならば
この誰かがということなんです
誰ですかというと この汚れから離れてない人
心の汚れから それだけじゃなくてアペート
離れているアペートというのは 2行目の離れている
ダマというのは自己制御なんですね
自己管理 自己管理から離れているアペート
それはダマという言葉だけつなげてサッチェーナという言葉もあります
サッチェーナというのは真理
真理 本当のこと このダマサッチェはもう出家だけではなくて
在家にも誰にでも必要なんですよ
自己管理とみんな真理を目指さなくちゃいけないんですよ
ずっと騙されて生活することはいいわけじゃないんですよ
人間不幸になるんですよ
例えば科学の世界ではいろんな真理を発見すると同時に
我々の生活水準がどんどん高くなって
どんどん楽に生きられるようになっていく
なぜ病気になるのかと調べたところで
病気の原因やら病気になることをいろいろ発見したりするでしょうに
そういうことによって
我々は極簡単に病気を治すということは今できているんですね
簡単で速くて すぐ病気を治してもらう
だから いろんなものについて真理というものがあるんですよ
正しいものって それを発見しなくちゃいけない
それがオートモードで自動的に生まれつき付いてるわけじゃないんですね
生まれつき全て知ってる人っていうのは生まれてこないんです
そういう言ってる人がいますけど
世の中で でもあれは嘘言ってるんです
生まれつき私は全部知ってるんだぞという人がいますけど
完璧な嘘言ってるんです
人間というのは生まれてからいろいろ勉強するんです
いろいろ発見するんです
ですから 我々は生まれてきたならば
その日から真理は何なのかと探し求めなくてはいけないんです
で それでもって人生っていうのはうまく成功していきます
俗世間ではもうそんなに大胆な真理探してないんですよ
田んぼを作っている人だったら
まあ米はね 豊作になるためにどうすればよろしいかというぐらいで
まあ納得してそれでストップする
それ自分のその仕事分野の中で
なんとか身についたらそれでストップしちゃうんですね
人生は 普通の世界ではそれぐらいのことで
通訳者になりたいと仕事として思った人は
自分が何語の通訳者と決めて
その言語を勉強して その使い方を全部身についたところで
迷いと で 人生 真理探すことはそれでストップしちゃうんですよ
だから当然ながら人間っていうのは狭い範囲で生きてるんですね
しかし 何から何まで勉強しようと思ったら
これはもう事実上無理ですね
だからいくつか選ばなくちゃいけないんですね
自分の専門分野 仕事を選んでやらなくちゃいけない
それにもかなり時間がかかります
音楽を選んだ人はこれを一生苦労しないと音楽は身につかないし
スポーツを選んだ人も時間そればっかりやらないと仕事にならないというふうなところで能力の問題が出てくる
しかし 全ての人は生きているんですよ
生きているんだから仕事をしているんですよ
仕事は大事じゃないんですよ
生きているんだからやっているんですよ
生きていないと誰も仕事はしないんですね
面白いことに 言ってることはみんな仕事はすごい大事なことだと言ってるんだけど
生きてないとやらないし
勉強ほど大事なことないよと言ってますが
生きてない場合はそれもやらないんだから
やっぱり生きていることは一番大事なんですよ
どう考えても 本当は勉強も仕事も何でも家族作ることも結婚することも
生きていることがうまく流れるための道具なんですよ
だからなんでみんな悩んだり困ったりするかというと
それをわかってないんだから単純な論理ですけどね
仕事で悩んでるだったら辞めた方がいいんですよ
なぜならば この人は悩んできてるんだから
道具が役に立ってないんですよ
車は買ったんだけど動けないんだよと言ったら
もう何のためにあるんですかね
だから役に立たなくなっちゃいますね
だから結婚はしたんだけど
その日からものすごいもう不幸で苦しいんだと
いうのはやっぱりこの真理わかってないんですよ
だから飛び出して何かやるんではなくて
私はこういうことをするのはもう楽しく気楽に生きるためですよと
その目的は達成できますかと
何かする前にやっぱり考えた方がいいんですよ
それは誰も考えません
だから世の中でいつでも人間はこれほど科学的に発展しているのに
人生だけは昔と同じ 大変苦しい
殺される恐れが今もある
昔もありましたからね
首狩り民族みたいな時代で
だって外の世界知らないんだからね
自分がどこかで生活していて
動物とかね それで獲物を取って食べている
そこでちょっとでもそこら辺に間違っていったら
そちらに住んでいる人々にとっては獲物と同じものだから
殺しちゃいます 怖くなるので同じものを見ると
鹿とか見たると見ると
あ これもう殺して食べてもいいんでしょうし
ライオン見たらもうまあ逃げろうと
ライオンに食べられるんだからということになるんですけど
同じ人間見たらどうすればいいんですかね
これわからなくなりますね
だからもうすぐ怖くなっちゃって殺しちゃう
だから原始時代の人間は軽々く旅はできませんでしたね
今どうですかね 今もう同じでしょうね
飛行機なんかに乗るとか
どれぐらいいじめられるかと
預かり荷物なんか一旦検査して預かった瞬間から触ることさえも禁止ですよ
みんな知らないんです
触れないんだからね 一旦一旦触れ触ったらもう乗せません
飛行機に まあ立ち入り禁止だから触ることは不可能だけど
これそれで気がつかない
もしお願いして ちょっと何か忘れたなんとか言ってね
もう一度返してくれと言ったら
また外に戻持って行って
また検査ルートで持ってこいと
という風になるんです
それもやっぱり死の恐怖ですよ
今もそう簡単に旅できない状態
だから他のこと見たっても
やっぱり科学は発展しているんだけど
我々は死ぬ恐怖 殺される恐怖感で
あらゆる苦しみで騙される恐怖感で盗まれる恐怖感で生活せなくちゃいけないんですね
だから人生は楽になってないんですよ
だから科学やら蓄積の知識やらね
そんなのは勉強するより勉強は必要ですけど
もうちょっとあなた方にあるんじゃないんですかっていうのはブッダの話なんです
もっと大事なもの 科学よりも物理学よりも地理学よりも音楽よりもすごい大事なことあるんだよ
生命であるならば 誰でも勉強するべきものがあるんだよと
それはやらないんだから
ものすごい誠に残念なこと
それはどういうことかって
生きるっていうことなんですよ
生きることって何なのかという学問は誰もやりません
そういう学問もない だからお釈迦様は語った仏教はその学問なんです
宗教ではありません 宗教というのは何かに頼って何かを信仰して
まあおねだりすることです
はっきり定義決まってます
死後 永遠の命をもらおうと
商売はちょっとずるいんですけどね
何か得るためにはそれぐらいのものは払わなくちゃいけないんですけどね
ちょっとお祈りしただけで永遠の命っていうのは
ちょっと期待はね まあありすぎですね
まあ宝くじ論理ですよ
だから宝くじ論理ではもうもうほとんど当たらないってことになりますね
だからまあそれを置いておいて
まあ何かそうやっておねだりするような教えではない
それは宗教の世界で それおねだりしたっても
その人はどう生きるべきかということがわからないんだからね
永遠な天国あるならば
今人を殺したってもいいんですよ
自爆テロやったってもいいんですよ
なぜならば 死んだらすぐもう天国に
まあ神のために死にましたからね
場所を用意しているんだよと
だからそうやってテロを訓練する人々っていうのは
本当は生きてないんですね
楽しく食べて 家族を作って
親孝行して おじさんばあさんになって死ぬという普通の生き方はしないんですよ
だから生きてないんですね
だから宗教でもこの問題は扱ってないんです
生きる論というのは お釈迦様だけですよ
まあ孔子の思想でもね
まあ社会で平和で生きるためにいろいろ親孝行すること
いろいろ語ってはいるんですけど
範囲は狭いんですね ただ
目で見える そのその日常の生活
それでもできるだけ長生きすると
美味しいものを食べてというぐらいですから
まああまりにも深みには行ってないんですね
うん それが仏教では真理という一言葉にまとめる
この だから真理を知るということは
仏教の立場から真理を知るということは
この音楽を勉強するようなものではありません
そちらにもある真理がありますよ
ある法則があって いろいろ法則があって
いろいろ決まりがあって
それの中でちゃんと勉強した人は音楽家になってね
ただ楽器を叩いただけで
演奏家でも音楽家でも何でもないんですね
ピアノを叩くぐらいは猫にもできますからね
上歩いていけば音が出ますからね
それでいい曲ですよということになりません
だからそちらにもそれなりの真理がありますが
まあ仏教ではやっぱり生きるということについての真理は
誰でも必ずもやらなくちゃいけない真理
それやってないんだから
たとえ音楽家になっても
人生はガタガタで不幸で落ち着かない
医学のプロになっても
自分の人生はもうどうでしょうかと
仕事はきついと 難しいと
心配だと 結局生きる技はわからないんだから
幸福になることはなかなか大変難しいんですね
たまたまうまくいっている人々いうことにみんな乗せられる
それはあまりにも屁理屈だからなんですよ
家族 環境やら仕事やら
何一つ問題なくうまくいっている
いるんではないか そんな宗教なんかなくてもというんです
何人いるんですかと 統計的に調べないと
百万人に一人 家族ぐらいはうまくいってるんだからといって
それは普遍的な事実じゃないでしょうに
地球上の人間の中で平和で安らかで
これっていう問題なくいるって人々どれぐらいいるんですかと
いないとは言えませんだけど
もうたまたまうまくいってるということもあるんですが
なんでその例だけ見て
無意味なことを言うんでしょうかと
だから八回 何かに百回頑張ったところで
一回成功すると必ず成功しますよと言えますかね
言えるのはほとんど負けますよということでしょうね
だって回もう負ける確率性ありますから
我々はこの百分の１じゃなくて一億分の１が正しいと
一億分の１ぐらいの確率性をね
プロバビリティーというもの
それをお釈迦様は認めません
だから見れば見るほど人間というのは苦しんで生きているんだから
人生は苦しいという風にした方がいいんじゃないかと
たまたま楽しかったんだから
人生は苦しくではありませんというのはもう嫌なんですね
聞きたくもないぐらいのバカバカしい考え方なんです
いつでもそれにはもう反論されますからね
そんなこと言ったっても
生きることはすごい楽しいんだよと
よく言うこと  [笑い]言いながらまた格好もつけます
あなた方より我々はすごい教育レベルが高いんだよと
だから恥かいているのは誰ですかねと聞きたいんですけど
教育レベルが高いと言ったって
もう言ってることは何なのかと
だから人生 人間の世界を調べてみると
もうほとんどの人々はかなり苦しんで生きているのに
いえ 苦しくないんだよと
だってあの人が大変楽で幸せで生きているんではないかというだけのことで
では あんたその人のことを行って調べたんです？いえ
調べませんと 近寄れない人ですよということになるし
大体そうやってみんな口を開けたらとてつもない
もう人間言ってはいけないほどの恥ずかしい屁理屈ばっかりペラペラ朝から晩まで喋っている
それずっと聞いてる我々の苦しみもちょっと考えてほしいんですよ
論理的に世の中見ているんだから
また時々相手にもしてあげなくちゃいけないんですよ
かなり苦しいんですよ
この屁理屈に付き合うということはね
まあそれで今説明したのは
この何でしたっけ ダマサッチャという 2つの言葉
ダマは自己制御 これは当然必要ですよ
人間が感情で生きているんだから
自己管理ないんですね
正中観は壊れているんですよ
怒りが出たら何やってるか分からなくなる
欲が出てきたら何をやってるか分からなくなります
無知が出たら何をやってるか分からなくなる
だから正中観が壊れている機械を動かしてはいけません
動かす前にきちんとした正中観
コントロールパネルをつけてもらわないと
それを修理しないと 人生のコントロールパネル
コントロールボードというもの
それはダマという言葉
サッチャは真理 そこでブッダが語る真理っていうのは
生命であるならば 誰でも必ずしも理解しなくちゃいけない真理であって
それが一番大事であって
誰でも目指すのは幸福というものですからね
で お釈迦様はあらゆる幸福を説いて教えて
究極的な幸福を何にも依存しない
完全に独立した幸福って何なのかと
そこまで語っているんです
いわゆる条件付きの幸福っていうのは壊れます
優しい両親に育てられるんだから
子供は幸福ですよと言っても
それはそれほど大事な幸福じゃありません
なぜならば この親が優しくている間の幸福だからね
親がいつ頭が狂ってバカをやるかわからない
親が子供殺すんだから
人間だけはね 動物はやりませんだけど
だから親が精神的に落ち着いているだけの話ですよ
だから本当に確実に優しい親に育てられた子が幸福ですよ
すごい楽しく すくすくと成長しますよ
これは問題ありません
しかし それこそ究極的な幸福やとは言いにくいんです
親が死んだらどうするかと
あるいは仕事終わったらどうするかと
自分がもう成長して終わってからどうするかと
もう優しい親のお世話いらなくなるんだから
それから不幸 だからどんな幸福でも
条件の中で成り立つものはすぐ壊れるんだよと
だから無条件の幸福っていうものを目指さなくちゃいけない
因縁によらない幸福を目指さなくちゃいけないんだと
というところまでお釈迦様は幸福論を語っている
それは真理の世界 病気になる原因
本当の原因を見つけたら
その病気が治せる方法を見つけるように
それでよかったでしょうに
同じく真理を発見することは幸福の発見にもなります
それでこの人がアペートダマサッチェーナ
アペート 離れている ダマからもサッチャからも
もうゴミですね そうすると
性格の管理もないし 真理目指しているわけでもないし
皆様の社会ででも何も勉強するつもりはない
仕事をするつもりはまるっきりないと
もう産んだ母も嫌になるんですよ
父親も「うちの子はもうもう 28 ですけど」と 「
家にこもりっきりで もう何も勉強もしたくない
大学も中退しました」とかね 「
外にも出かけない」とかね
なんとか強引に怒鳴って貶して殴って脅して仕事なんか見つけてあげても 1週間で辞めるとかね
そういう子はもうもう嫌なんですよ
いわゆる真理を目指すということは
普通の社会から見ても大変大事なことなんですよ
勉強するは 新しいものを探し求めるは
新しい能力 テクニック
ノウハウは身につくるようにすると
親がもうすごく喜ぶね 「
うちの子はもう元気で
いろんなことを何やってるかわからないんだけど
いろんなことをやってるんだよ」と
仕事を頑張ると 親がすごくそれで喜ぶでしょうし
社会もそういう人は必要とするでしょうし
もし人間が自己管理もなく真理も目指さないんだったら
もうゴミですね はっきりと
だから社会にいてはならないゴミで
だから社会に迷惑で 危険な存在にまでになってしまう
そういうことで どうしても必要なことはダンマサッチャですね
それで結論は「ナ」というのはありません
そう 彼がカーサワンアラハティ
この袈裟を着るためにはナアラハティ
ふさわしくない このアラハティっていうのは
この阿羅漢という言葉も同じです
で お釈迦様も阿羅漢であって
最終解脱の境地は初期仏教では阿羅漢と言うんですね
最終的に悟ったら阿羅漢
阿羅漢になったというんですね
阿羅漢の言葉は「ふさわしい人間になりました」
いわゆる完璧な人間になったということなんです
全部資格取りましたと
もうやることはないんだという状態なんですね
性格的に この阿羅漢というのはふさわしい人
いわゆる完全な人ということでね
使っていて こちらでそんな意味で使っているわけじゃないんですね
まあふさわしくないと
あなたに資格がないんだよと
袈裟を着る資格がないんだよ
だから袈裟を着る資格っていうのは
まあ心を汚れからきれいにして離れていることと
自己制御と慎慮を獲得している
その人は袈裟に完全にふさわしいと
では出家って何なのかというと
やっぱり仕事をしているんですよ
完璧にふさわしいというわけではないんだけど
その学校に入って真剣に勉強したり研究したりしているんです
だから音楽を勉強したければ音楽家のところに行かないと
その人は最初から楽器を触ったり
楽譜も自分で音楽を書いたりしなくちゃいけないんですよ
だからその人も音楽の世界の一人なんです
が 一人前というわけじゃないんです
それでまた 音楽の学生が何かバイオリンとか持っていくと
お前偉そうなバイオリン持ったってまだ一人前プロじゃないんだから
それを触るなかれと言えますかね
それは言えませんね 君は音楽の学生だから
一生懸命立派なバイオリンを買って
プロ用のものを買って練習しなさいと言いますから
やっぱり出家したんだからで完全に悟ったっていうことは全くない話で
なぜ出家するかというと
この悟る 悟るための学校に入門する
そうすると全部そちらの道具を使うっていうことは当たり前なこと
で こちらで言っていることは
この袈裟は 袈裟はふさわしくないと
それで これは皆様に役に立たない教えですかと
それも考えてほしい こちらで言っているのはね
あんた着ている服にふさわしいかということなんです
その服にふさわしいか
例えば人間 なんで服をブランドのものやらいろんなものを着ていますかというとね
自分が豊かで贅沢 楽しく生きてるんだぞって見せるためでしょ
本当にそうですかと ふさわしいですか？着てる服
服だけかっこよくて心はどうですかと
だから服着ただけで本物になりませんよ
昔は王家 制度あった時は王であることは象徴するために服なんですね
結局は 冠があって 何か首にかける何かあって
腕にはめる何かあったりとかね
すごい宝石いっぱい付けてる刀とかね
いくつか道具あるんですね
だからそういうものを持って国王だと言えます
しかし それが私たち身についたっても国王になりますかね
まあわからないでしょうね
議員バッジありますよ
あれは議員は付けますよ
あれどこかで作るもんでしょ
それ見たら簡単に作れます
そんな大したものじゃないんですね
あれは 作りもすごい単純で
菊の花だったっけね 菊の花の形で
だから一番簡単ですよ
作るの おそらく 18金でしょうね
まあお金かかりませんね
1万円ぐらいで作れます
それで作ってつけてみてください
議員になるかと 台湾とかタイとかね
そこら辺に南無に持っていってサンプル取って
何でできているんですかとか
国会なんか見学に行けばね
そういうのありますからね
選べればとても簡単に情報入りますしね
だからもう向こう行く時頼めばもう 1 日 2個ぐらいね
作ってくれますよ それ作って
あるいはそれを実際に作っているところで一つちょうだいと言えば
まあそれはもう一つもらえないわけではないです
そんなのはもうつけていても議員になるわけじゃない
そこで死んだ議員たちやらね
議員終わった人とかね
家で持ってるでしょうね
それを その子供がそれつけていると
だからお釈迦様それ言ってるんですよ
ただ何か仮面かぶったんだからといって
神の仮面かぶったんだからって神になれないんだよと
鬼の仮面かぶっても鬼になれるわけないんだよと
世の中はいつでもこの表の殻
それで終わり 全て 表面見て形見て
はいはい その人はこういう人ですと決めつけちゃう
これがあまりにも危険で気をつけましょうと
皆様もその心理知ってるんだから
人が議員バッジつけてのあんたおかしいですよと言うだけで終わりますけど
それは心理知ってるだからなんですよ
あれちょっとおかしいなと
しかし 日常生活どうですかね
全てそれで決めつけてるんです
服を見た途端もうすごい立派な人だと
決めちゃうそういう弱みがすごくあるんです
それはすごく危険 遊びじゃない
だからいつでも中身っていうこと
プレゼントの包装をすっている紙じゃないんですよ
大事なのは 中身なんですよ
中身より箱大事だったらね
まあ誰かにあの技術者に注文して箱を作ってもらって
漆塗って まあプレゼントの箱だからね
一回しか使えないもんですよ
中にビロード なんとか布をちょっとちょっと中に草履 1枚
2つではなくて ペアと言いますから
英語だったらね 一つだけ入れて
使ったものを ちゃんと包装してプレゼントしてみてください
箱は立派でしょう だからやっぱり中身は大事っていうことになるんです
その弱みは人間にあります
みんなにあります 服を見たら決めてしまう
私も服を見て決めますよ
私は決めるのは服を 服を通して性格を見るんです
どんな立派な高価な服を着ても
本人が自分の心を使って着なくちゃいけないんだからバレます
見事にバレます バレないのはこの
例えばこの舞台とかね
このテレビに出たりとか
その場合はこの技術者が服を着させてあげる
その時は服はしっかりしています
お化粧もしっかりしています
しかし それでも人は見えますからね
見える人にはね それ以外はね
誰もプロのね そうやってデザイナーとか持っていないでしょ
自分で服を着る 自分でお化粧するんだからね
だから まあ心の働きを知っている人は誤魔化せませんだけど
世の中っていうのは心っていうのはないっていう状態で生きているんだからね
やっぱりみんな騙されちゃって
かなり苦労する 不幸になることにはなります
本人も騙されます カッコつけていると
自分が本当にカッコいい人だと勘違いする
だからお釈迦様は一貫して心の汚れをなくせ
人格をしっかりしなさいと
悪いことは絶対やめなさいということ一貫して言うんだから
それが一番最高なもので優先であって
他はまあそこそこでやってもやらなくてもいいっていうこと
だから人間生きる場合は
この自分の心清らかにすることは絶対的な大事なことであって
まあ生きる上で必要なものはそこそこ他のものをやればいいんですよ
そんなに神経を使う必要ない
仕事でもあまりにも苦しくて
収入もそれほどよくないんだったら
もう辞めちゃえばいいし
他のことをすればいいしという簡単単純な生き方でいいです
今はやっているのはこういう色だからといってね
どうでもいいんですよ
自分にある服を着ちゃえばね
みんな青い色の服を着ているね
自分にとってはもう天気荒れ全部調べたところで
もう赤い服がありまして
まあそれは楽でそれ着て
あんたちょっと違うでしょ？に
今はやってるのは青いんですからとか
あ そうですか なるほど
それで終わりますからね
ああ 嫌だ なんで私は時代遅れ遅れているんでしょうかとかね
そんな考える必要ないんです
何葬式なんかに必ずしもあの黒い変な服を着ていかなくちゃいけないんですかね
だから 例えば仕事をしているしている途中でサッと行って最後の挨拶して帰ると
できないんですね 自分で自分の生き方を苦しくしてるだけでしょうに
仕事してた時 誰か誰か亡くなった
知ってる人とかいたら
その場でまあちょっと仕事ちょっと休んで
もうちょっと出かけてきますからとかね
そのまま行って どういうことかと思って挨拶するなり何かするなりね
また仕事に戻るとか それはできませんね
それでまたレンタル屋さんに行くか
また明日に行くかとか
また調べて またそれ適当な服
服を持っていってとかね
そこまでやる必要あるんでしょうか
それただ忙しいのに もっと忙しくなるだけなんです
だからこの気楽で生きればいいんですよ
しかし 我々いろいろしきたり決めちゃうと気楽がなくなっちゃうんですね
結婚式で立派な文章で祝福をするのは悪くないんだけど
能力あればね そういう文学的な真っ直ぐな能力あるとかね
万歳し見た目持っているような言葉の使い方
いろいろ工夫している人であるならば
すごいかっこ聞く言葉喋ってもよろしいし
だからってみんなその真似をすると最悪でしょうに
だから下手な人は下手でよろしいし
それが色がバラエティがいっぱいあって
例えば誰かのおじい様が
もう私は詳しくわからへんけど
とにかく頑張りなさいよと
しっかり成人しなさいよと挨拶して座って何が悪いんですかね
例えばおじいさんが まあ自分の息子に孫にたい
まあこの人は若い時はね
いろんなバカなことやってましたよと
これからはそれやめなさいよと
言って座ったら何かが悪いんですかね
すごい雰囲気が穏やかになるでしょうに
神経質でいる もう何ですか
何て言いますか 親御さんじゃなくて
あの その二人にしたってもね
恥ずかしいこと言われるなとかね
そうするとなんとなく気持ちが穏やかになるでしょうに
だから気楽でいいのに
人間というのはわざわざといろんな決まり
形作る 形作って その裏で逃げようとするんですよ
だから 例えば公で完璧な正しい日本語で語れないんですよ
それで決まり文句があって
できたテキストがあって
そういうテキストを書いて読み上げて仕事を果たしたと
自分がそこで逃げ隠れるんですね
それで隠しどうしますかと
結婚式で立派な文章で読み上げたんだからといって
この人はすごい能力ある人だという風になりますかと
だから私は日本語で来る手紙はもうそこら辺は全部飛ばす
読めません 時々 1ページも読めないで捨ててしまうんだ
2ページ目から内容だけ読む
決まり文句ザーッとザラザラと並んでるんだからね
で あの それでこのこのこのこちらでお釈迦様は本当にピンポイントしているのは
この表面的な形は意味があるではあるわけではないと
本当は中身ですよと わかりやすく言えば
服にふさわしい人間にならなくちゃいけないので
動物は裸でそれでいいんですよ
何でも明確で裸のまんまの生き方で怒ったらすぐわかるし
で すごく楽なんですよ
我々は文化人として服を着ているんですよ
だったら精神的にはしっかりした文化人にならなくちゃいけないんですよ
人間が本当に精神的に文化人ですかと
ないでしょうに 銀行強盗するわ
横領するわ 不倫するわ
よこしまな行為するわ
嘘をつくわ 人殺しはするわ
やりたい放題 動物もやらないことをやって服でごまかす
ということなんです だから
いかに心の育ち方が大事ですかと
で それはその意味です
で 十番目は説明しなくても九番目の反対ですよ
ヨッチャワンタカサーワッサシーシーレスーサマヒトーウペトーダマサッジェーナサウェーカサーワマハテ
ィヨッチャワンタカサーワッサシーレナササマヒトーウペトーダマサッジェーナサウェーカサーワマハティ
という経なんです ヨッチャ
誰かがワンタカサーワッサ
ワンタっていうのは吐いて出しています
吐き出すこと 何を カサーワ
汚れ 心の汚れを で ワンタっていうことはちょっと力が強いんですよ
私たちはいいやと何かいろんなものを捨てたりするでしょ
捨ててもやっぱり欲しいとまた拾ったりするんです
食べる時でも もうあんまり食べ過ぎは良くないんですから
やっぱり食べないことにしましょうと
して やっぱりちょっとだけやって
またまた手がいくんですよ
だから人間 普通のやめました
やめましたって言ったっても
全然あてになりません
私はタバコやめます ああそうですかと
それだけのことなんですよ
酒やめます ああそう 私なんぞはそれで終わり
信頼できてない だからがっかりもしないんですよ
だからその人は後でまた酒飲むことになっても
私って何の恥もなく喋れますよ
もともと別に やると思っていなかったし
途中で心変えることもあるんだよ
そんなこと それでやっぱりスイスイ飲むことになり
ああそうですかそういう風になります
私は まあ冗談でからかうためにもまあなんとか言うかもしれませんだけど
あれはあくまでも冗談で
全然気にしていない しかし
ワンタ 吐いたという場合はどうですかね
なんか食べて吐き出したと
やっぱりまた気が変わりますかね
その場合はもう いくら気が数秒すぐ変わる人であろうとも
吐い-ものに対しては気が変わりませんね
人が履いたものじゃない
自分が履いたものですけど
だからこの心の汚れはそれぐらいの気持ちで捨てるんです
まあそれはその場合も阿羅漢の強調言ってますけどね
あとで気が変わることはないんです
それからシーリーススサマヒト
シーラっていうのは戒律のことをスサマヒトというのはちゃんと守っていると
それあの ダムサッチャのダムの説明なんですね
行儀作法をちゃんと守っていると
ウペートっていうのは空いてます
アペートの反対ですね
何が空いてますかと ダムサッチャ
自己管理も真理ももう身に付いています
スリカーサマラ その人は袈裟を着るためにふさわしい人であると
これは阿羅漢のことを言ってるんですね
まあわかりやすく言えば
衣着たんだからって坊主にならないんだよと
服でランクつけるんじゃない
心で優れと 精神的に優れている人は上やと
たとえ子供であろうと
ランク付けあります それはどれぐらい精神的に優れているかないか
どれぐらい真理近いかないかと
だから仏教の世界では
出家の世界でも やっぱり先に出家した年上で年上なんですが
実際のお釈迦様の真理のランク付けで
やっぱり悟った人々は一番上なんです
年は全然効かない 出家しているかないかも気にしない
誰よりも喜びに悟ってすごいと
喜びから喋っている人々の上から嫌いからされるのはトップやと
それで阿羅漢になった人は一番最高やと
その人は男か女か 出家しているかないか
それは関係ない そんなのはもう関係
全くも関係ないと だから精神的な心のそれって方によってブッダがランク付けてるんですね
そういう偈をなぜ説いたかというエピソード
物語もありますが この物語はこのなんかラージャガハという町で
かなりお坊さんも住んでいる都心でしたからね
で このサーリプッタ尊者とモクレン尊者がそちらにたまに旅をしている間
たまに行ったんですよ
その二人はいろんなところで歩いているし
お釈迦様もいろんなところで歩いているし
そういうすごい発展している巨大な街なんかには
そんな長い時間はいないんですね
田舎 遠いところでよく歩いたり
人々にできるだけ 今みたいなマスコミの方法なかったんだからね
行って口で喋れないと
そういうことでよく旅をしていましたし
で ラージャガハに来たら
ラージャガハの人々はもう大なる部隊が増えたからね
大変みんな集めてお布施したりいろいろあって
それでまあ 1 日しかいなかったでしょうね
来るとたくさんの坊さんたちと一緒に来るんですよ
一人では大体 200 300人ぐらいは一緒に行くんです
お坊さんたち で みんな修行中だから
サーリプッタ尊者にずっと付いて行くんですよ
それはいきなりたくさんの人々が来ると
仏教の人々はもうすぐもうすぐ決めて
お布施とか何とかしなくちゃいけないんだと
それで ある人がものすごい高価な服を持ってきて
服って言ったって布ですね
持ってきて その人々に
このお布施用意している人々にあげたんだよ
自分の分として 私はこれは差し上げますと
もし料理やらお坊さんたちにあげる他のお布施のものをやら
何か足らなかったら これすぐ売って
使ってくださいと かなり高価なんです
自分にとってもあまりにも高価すぎて着られないでしょうね
だからせっかくこれはお坊さんのためにお布施で来ていれば
それはすごくいいことということで
その人はこれをしたんです
しかし 信者さんも信者さんで全部集めていたんだから
何一つ足らなかったものはなかったのです
それでこれはどうしようかと
で 互いにあの布どうしようかと
言ったらみんな人間考えるんですね
これはしょうがないと
もうお布施しましょうと
その人はお布施でお布施したものだから
お布施しましょうと そうするとお布施しましょうったって
これは 1枚しかないし
誰かにあげなくちゃいけない
誰か一人に ではどんな坊さんにお布施しましょうかなと話し合った結果
誰かだってさんにあげましょうと
お釈迦様が子僧と企んだお釈迦様の親戚なんですけど
なんでその人にあげるかと思ったら
この人は人気者なんですね
この王舎城に ラージャガハの日本語で王舎城と言いますからね
そちらによって永住ですよ
楽で贅沢もできるし で
宮殿から毎日ご飯も来るし
それでだいたい彼がよく人の機嫌を取ることはよく上手なんですよ
だからみんな知っている
人気もある みんなに愛されている
誰にもよく聞くお坊さんだと
しかし 喋る時だけは お釈迦様まで批判になるように喋る
出家は托鉢でしか生活してはいけませんよと
お釈迦様の弟子たちは何なのかと
そんな感じなんですよ
自分が何やってるか それは気にしない
贅沢していたんですよ
贅沢しているんだけど
口だけはすごい苦行を喋っているんですね
絶対肉 魚なんか口にするもんじゃないんだよと
で 自分が宮殿から注文してご飯を食べる
その場合は菜食主義でできますけど
人からものを頂いたものを食べるお釈迦様にとっては何者かわからないんだから
食べるものも腐ったものもいろんなものもらいますからね
お釈迦様は本当に苦しい生活をしているのに
この人は毎日ちゃんと用意した料理を食べているんです
それはもしかすると もしかするとではなく
用意してもらうものは当然菜食主義になるんですよ
お坊さんのために動物を殺したり
魚を取ったりしているよりは食べてはいけないと戒律もありますからね
だから必然的に菜食主義になるんです
でも托鉢に出たところで
誰かが魚を焼いていて
お坊さんに託宣できる
当然それはあげるんですよ
だから え これはダメですよという権利はないんです
例えば日本でそれほど見られませんですけど
アメリカでもどこでもありことで
みんなものを乞うんでしょう
ないもの人々は お金いくらかちょうだいと
そういう人々にいくらあげるかというと
あげる人の勝手でしょうに
例えば自分が 100円あげて
100円ではないんです
私は 1500円ですよ
言えますかね だから もらう人には上限はつけることはできません
そういうことで お釈迦様はそういう苦労して生活してきたんですけども
だからこの人はもう結構贅沢していて
人気もあって だからとにかく人の形見た
表面的なところだけ見た
で サーリプッタ尊者とモクレン尊者っていうのは
かなり節操な生活をしている
しかし 釈尊の第1第2番目の弟子二人なんです
ブッダより次に偉いんです
しかし 着ている衣を見てもボロでしょうしね
もう苦しく もうすごい節操な生活
そんな気にしないんだからね
だから一般の人々と比べれば
それをこの布をあげる気にはならないんですね
まああげたってもおそらく着ないだろうと
誰かにあげるでしょう
だからデーヴァダッタ尊者だったら
もうデーヴァダッタさんだったら
もういつでも王様の上だから
みんなとの格差っているし
これはちゃんと着るでしょうと
それで大仏だとか大仏だと
すぐそれでものすごい高価なものをもらったんだから
すぐそれで衣を作って
かなりド派手に衣を着て街で歩いたりする
それ見たところでなんかみんなあれ
これちょっと違うんじゃないかなと
こんな身を張ってね 胸を張ってすごい高価な衣をね
それはちょっと道が違うんじゃないかと
仏教はいくらかは知っているんだからということで
すごく話に話題になります
それでけしからんと 偉大なる釈尊さえもすごい質素な生活をしているのにね
こんなもうだらしない人はね
衣で身を張ろうとしたって
もうこれはけしからんではないかと話題になったところで
お釈迦様は大仏尊者をけなすことでも批判することでもなく
真理としては人間の大事なところはおめとの殻ではありませんと
心の管理と制御と真理を発見することであると
という意味のこの偈を教えたんです
だからこの人間というのはいつでも形で決めちゃいますよ
だから私は国行ったら
何かいろいろ仕事を断るとか
いろんなことをやってもらいたい場合は
もうなんとか見た目がいい衣でもないかと
そういうものを着て行ったら
すぐうまくやってくれる
普通は寺で仕事をしたりする時の着ているボロのまんまで
どこへでも行くんです
そのままで汚れたまんまで全然気にしないんですけど
そういうふうな形で どこへ行って
何か知っている人々でないところに行っちゃうとダメですね
何もやってくれない ゴミ扱いする
だから衣がちょっと汚れていると
もう人はゴミだと すぐそういうことになって
私はまた他の日で全く別日に別な形で
その時はすごく恥かげられます
その時 まあ本当立派な人々はみんな言うことをやってくれますからね
言って私も口も聞かない
言わないでね 誰かにあなたに頼みなさいと言って
みんな言ってこういうことをしてくださいと言ったら
なるほど それだと恥かかれます
だからやっぱりしょうがないんですけど
人間の弱みだからね そうやってこういうことになります
この間 総理大臣 今国のね
いましたけど だからお坊さんたちはチームぐらいでね
どっちにしても私はどんな立場いたって
私は上で年上でね まあだからお坊さんたちはまあ全部この挨拶やらなんだかんだで
まあ先生がやってもらわないと困りますと
まあいいやと言って 私はまあもう全部時間やら全部その時間に決めてたから
リリースしますから それなりにやってくださいと
まあそういう祝福とかね
で それはもう総理ばかりはね
どう見たってもみんな立派なギンギラの衣を着ているかもしれませんだけど
またよくご飯食べて もうすごいピンピン体持ってるかもしれませんだけど
見たら誰がしっかりとみんなを抑えて管理しているかってわかるはずなんですよ
で 私はいくつかのことをやってはいけないとみんなに最初に言ったんです
時間もなくなるし これとこれとこれはカットだと
で この時間しかないし
もう遅くなったし だから私も早く帰りたいし
そいつすごく疲れているんだよと
だから私たちは早く仕事終わった方が総理大臣にとっても休めるしっていうことを説明してやったのに
で 一応私はもうちゃんとね
祝福の言葉や感謝の言葉もすっごい短く
ちらっと言って終わったんです
ピッと死なんです この若者たちがまた何かもう意図を持ってきて
じゃあ一応祝福の意図でも
それでまあそれがまあそれでそういうこともありましたけど
よくあの教育もないお坊さんがいて
すごい体が大きい その坊さんを見て
そういうことですよと説教してるんですね
あの人は返事もする方ができないんですねって見て
それで私は面白くなったんですね
やっぱり なるほど あの人はすごく体が大きくて
食べ過ぎて まあお金はいいんだから
喋ってるんで 最初は私は挨拶しなかった
その人と 長い間会っていなんです
でも挨拶 他の人々いろいろしゃべったりしてるんで
私はそこになかったんですね
しかし 式を行うために座ったところで
自分がもうリーダーだから
みんなに一言言わないと
どうですか 元気ですかとか
この間とか 昔の話とかなんとか言って
そんなそれぐらいの人なんです
でもやっぱり形で一番上ってことになるんですね
そうすると何かアドバイスを求めてすれば
その人は誰にアドバイスを求めてるとその人から聞いたりするでしょ
それだとまたうまくいかないんですね
同じ人に なんか日本人が誰かお坊さんですけど
何かパーリの一番単純なパーリ語の 1行 2行なんですよ
これは日本語でどう言えばいいですかと
ただパーリ語がわからないんです
それで大使館に行って
大使館の人々に大使館の人々は学問勉強はしてるんだけど
パーリ語を知ってるってわけでもないし
一人ぐらいパーリ語をいくらか知ってる人はいたでしょうと思います
でも なんで大使館の最下の人々はもう誰でも知ってるサッババサからような芸に日本語つけてあげなくちゃいけない
大使館の人誰も日本語は知らない
だから英語で言って 誰かこのその場で電話を電話切りに行ったのは日本の女性でしたけど
おばさんでしたけどね
今スリランカ人の女の人ですけどね
だから彼女も知らないしね
どうしようかと 皆さんも私の教えて
私にこういうことを頼まれているんですけど
これはどうします？それで一応日本語つけて
こんなことですよと 心にあげなさいと
そのお坊さんが来て 何かそれやったんですね
お坊さん来て 日本のお坊さんたちも来て
我々も行って それで大使館から書いた文章をね
書いたのは私なんですけどね
頼んだお坊さんに そのお坊さんがすごく偉そうな顔をして
一応日本語はしましたけど
こういうことですよ ですけどね
だからこの形 表面的なところを見ると
一応人は惹かれるのは当然なことで
しかし本当の仕事になってくると問題起きるでしょうかと
やっぱりだから表面的に我々はいっぱいバッジをつけてもう生活して
もう中身がダメだったらね
問題なんです だから私たちもそういうバッジを見て偉い人だと決めたところで
これアドバイスくださいと頼んでも
向こうはできるんだから格好つけて何かできませんと言わないと
その人に限って 私はもうやりますよと一回言うと
もう 30分 百回ぐらいできませんって言ってます
ありますけど 簡単には言いません
面倒くさいし できないことははっきりもうできませんと言いますしね
でも あの 何て言いますか
そうやって見え見せている人っていうのはできませんということだけは言いませんね
だから大体知りません
これは知りません これはできませんという人はその時期で信頼できるんですよ
だから これは人間の世界でね
これはどんな世界であろうと
アメリカであろうか インドであろうか
自分の国スリランカであろうが
ミャンマーであろうがね
アフリカであろうが アフリカであろうが
これはどこにでもあることなんですね
そういうことで 中身が大事で
外の殻は気にするものではありません
と 外の殻でなくても 内容があるものはしっかりしたものですと
それは理解しないと残念ですと
それを理解してほしい
それわからないと我々はかなり悲しい状態になります
話は以上です  先生十のところでワンタカサーワの後にアッサってのがあるんですけども
これはどういう風に訳したらいいんですか？アッサって
アッサはカレーにでしょ
カレーにですか  アッサ誰か
ワンタカサーワ  ワンタカサーワアッサですね
なんでワンタカサーワアッサになるんですかね
上にアッサと  アッサはカレー
これは一応いろいろ強引な文法的なやり方ありますけど
アッサっていうのはカレーに C レース進めるままその戒律についても
まあ本当はヨチャワンタカサーワをそう戒律進む人だった方が文法的にはしっかりはしますけど
なるほど アッサはカサーワにつなげるんです
アッサカサーワナラハティ
アッサその人にカサーワン今朝を欲しがいですと
アッサカサーワン  という風につなげないと意味が通ります
しかし サレーカサーワンナラハティというだけでも文章は満たしてますけどね
これは今解読できませんだけど
私たちはもうそういうテキストは持ってます
一言葉一言葉に意味を付ける
これはシンハラ語でないとないんですから
これは注釈書だから アッサの立て方
パヒーナカサーワアッサ
意味はそのままなんですけど
日本語になると間違いはないんですけど
アッサっていうのは動詞みたい
煩悩がなくしているのであればという風に
そんな意味で訳せるんですよ
アッサは動詞もありますからね
条件を語る場合ですから動詞ですね
カサーをパヒーナ カサーをアッサ
煩悩をなくした者であるならばという
だからあの注釈書のそれは正しいんです
私は言った 前のものは正しくない
カサーワにつなげるというのは
その名詞でどっちもそうなりますからね
名詞で読むとね これ動詞ですね
じゃあカサーオーのオーが省略されたアッサというになっているっていう
あのワンタカサーオーでオーを省略して上にちょんとついてるという
それ聞いてるんですよ
三人のこと カサーをアッサ
えーと まああの アッサという意味がちょっとよくわからない
アッサの意味は動詞ですからね
あるならば  わかりました
ありがとうございました
えーと これミャンマーお坊さんに聞いたらば
いわゆる私も逆誤解しておりましてね
南伝のお坊さんは葬儀に関して一切関わらないのかどうかということを思ってお聞きしたらば
いやそうじゃないんだと
葬儀もやはりお坊さん関わり合っていたしますということでしたんでね
その辺がスリランカはどうなのかですね
ちょっとお聞きしたいんですが
どう程度の関わり合い？せいぜい前から一度お客さんとしては行きますよというふうに聞いたかと思うんですけれども
葬儀はもうお坊さんはどうでも関わりますよ
必ずしも行きます  関わり合うということは
ですから リーダーとして
儀式のリーダーとして関わり合うんですか？ とにかく葬式っていうものがありますから
葬式をお坊さんたちがやるんですよ
そうですね そうすると
日本のお坊さんが葬儀でやはりリーダーといますけども
それとは変わりなくなりますね
その部分だけ見た場合は
それは似ています  そうですね
極端にその部分で悪く言われるのはどうかなというところです
そんなこと言ってないですよ
わかりました  だから我々の場合は葬式やるための出家っていうことじゃないだけなことですね
で 葬式 お坊さんが行かないと
行っちゃうと大変なことになりますからね
必ずしも行きます 嫌がりますけど
お坊さんの方はね とにかくもう何か言い訳して
私は今日忙しいとか大変ですよ
集まるのは我々にとって
例えば 先祖さんがお坊さん 4人ぐらい欲しいと言うんですね
日本とそこだしいろいろ違いますから
お坊さん 4人欲しいやと 10人欲しいやと言われると
こちら 4人集まらなくちゃいけないし
寺の住んでる人は行くのはもうしょうがないんだから行かなくちゃいけないんだけど
もし寺に 2人しかいないと
もうもう2人呼ばなくちゃいけない
これ逃げますね いつでも
何か言い訳をして  日本は逆に喜んでいますけどね
向こうはそれはないんだからね
だからまあ 何か言い訳して逃げる
こちらもそれにいろいろ工夫しなくちゃいけない
まあ正直なところ 私でもあまり行きたいという気持ちはないんですね
別にあのことって無駄ではないかという気持ちがお坊さんたちも同じ気持ちですけどね
あれが無駄じゃないかなと
葬式っていうのはという気持ちはまあ出家は持っていて
在家はもう死んだ人がもう葬式されなかったら大変なことやとすごい考えているし
だから説法するときそれ言うんでどうったことはないんだ
そんなのは  [笑い]言うんだけど聞いてくれないんですね
私の説法では正直で説法しますよ
正直な説法で激しく読んで
言いたい時はね これだけで全部終わりと思ったら思い違いだと
どのように生きてきたかというね
それは で全部決めますよと
言うんですけど いい話でしたと
誤魔化しもなくちゃんと言ってくれたと言うんですよ
しかし また同じことを
もしかするとタイはお坊さんたちは喜んで葬式に行くと思います
で 結構布施もらいます
それでもまあそうですか
ミャンマーの葬式なんか見たことはないんです
私 タイではよく見ましたからね
かなりド派手で だから葬式しただけでお坊さんの用が済みましたと
あっち行けという生き方について私は色々言ってるんですね
仕事はそれで終わるもんじゃないんだと
あんなのくだらん仕事やと
やらなくてということやと
もっと仕事はあるんだと
でも誰でも人が死んじゃったらね
何かやりたい気持ちはありますから
やってはいけないわけじゃなくてね
まあそれはその時もう残された人々の気持ちの問題でね
もうきついんですよ あれは
なぜならばもう無意味だなと若い知ってるにも関わらずやらなくちゃいけないんですね
これでお父さんが成仏できますから
聞いちゃうときついんですよ
どう言えばいいんですかね
だから私は言うのは あなたは自分にできることをやりましたと
それで十分ですと 他のことを考える必要はないんだと
残された人々は自分の責任を果たすんだ
それをしっかりやりなさいと
しっかりやったという気持ちありますか？と
自分にできるだけ頑張って
それで十分ですと 安心しなさいと言って答えを出してないんだけど
本人がまたかえって錯覚するんですな
やっぱりこれでお父さんが成仏できだそう
それは言ってないんです
それは日本のことでも批判するときでも
それはかなりいろんなところで気をつけるんですよ
でもそれは あまり心に入らないんです
一つ真っ向から批判してないんです
ちょっと ちょっと ちょっと一言ケチをつけるぐらいのことで
別に本人が聞いたっても
まあまあ ただ笑って終わるような感じでは言ってるつもりですけど
論理によるとそうじゃないんです
それはもうイエスノーをはっきりしておかないと
だから大乗経典なんか私は分析しちゃうと厳しいんですが
大乗のお坊さんのことになってくると
どうせ私もみんな同じ人間だからね
まあ楽なことないんだよと
人間の生き方で完全性を目指すのは
これはもうあまりにも無理な話でね
だらしないところというのはあるのは人間だからね
だから出家生活はある面で
ブッダにはもうモデルとして模範的な生き方をしなくちゃいけないという厳しい決まりがあるんだけど
こちらの方ではできません
いくらなんでも 模範的に
かえってあまりにもしっかり模範的に見ると
最近の人々にしてたっても
なんかすごく扱いづらいというか
もう付き合いづらい 仲良くしたくないんですよ
いろいろだらしないところあるんだから
一般の人々も友達ぐらいの感じでいろいろ喧嘩もするわ
いろんなことも聞くわということで言ってるんですから
しかし 真理になってくると
物事ははっきりしておかないといけない
だから私は本当は般若心経というのは意味がないんだよと
はっきりと これは矛盾で成り立ってるんだよと
矛盾で書くなよということをはっきり言うんですけど
般若心経を大事に唱えてやってる人々は
まあそれは別にどうぞ頑張ってくださいと
人間の気持ちの問題だから
人の気持ちまで云々と言う必要はないんです
さあまあ 他何か質問とか
まあ反論とかあったらどうせ他の方々でもね
その先ほど言った葬式っていうのは
周りにいる人が心の汚れを少しでも落とした状態を作って
それが回向するということ以上の機能はないと思うんですけど
それだけで特別な場を設けて儀式を語っているのは
それだけの意味で理解したらいい
それだけのことです  いいとこに行った人には別にその回向があってなくても関係ないし
悪いところに行った人には非常にありがたいものなのかもしれないと
でも一生悪いことしている人は
ただその葬式で回向したっても受けるんですかね
受けたっても結局はいいことをしている人々は死んでから
もしかすると親戚がね
色々回向してくれるだろうという気持ちが成り立ちますけど
結局失敗する人はどうしても失敗ですよ
それは私の勝手な考え方で
私も疑問に思います 死んでから葬式をやって
ちゃんと正しい回向したっても受けなきゃ意味がないんですよ
向こうに だからやるわけないと思いますよ
もう一生精神的なことは嫌やと思ってた人がね
死んで突然やっぱりという人にはなりにくいしね
まあおっしゃる通り 葬式っていうのはほんのちょっと
ほんのちょっとの時間をね
心清らかにして 何かお徳を積んでお布施でもして
それは回向する それだけで
国によって違います ミャンマーではミャンマーのことを見たことはないんですからわかりませんし
タイではかなりものすごい派手で結婚式みたいな派手にやる場合もあるし
で スリランカの場合はだいたい三分で全部終わり
我々の仕事はもう三分以内で終わる
人々の話やら最後の別れの挨拶やら
これはもう何時間続くかわかりませんだけどね
だから家に行く時間と法事終わって帰る時間をまとめたら一時間で終わってるんです
しきたりには  十分もかからない
十分十分 まあいろいろみんなもうあれあれこちらこっち置いてください
そういう話に時間なくなりますからね
それでまあ説法はしますよ
説法はまあ十五分ぐらいでも散る
それもみんなそれでも長いという感じがしますな
それならば まあ俺たちはあまり面白いことは言わないし
どこへ行っても同じこと言ってくるんだから
もう みんな十五分でもまあ長い方です
葬式で説法しようとみんな私が言ったらやっぱり説法を聞こうと思いますよ
何よくわからないんだから
それはもう推測させません
だから私はもう喋り出したらみんなじっと聞こうとはする
それは期待外れないように
何か役に立つことは何か喋りますけど
その時はちょっと十五分飛んだりする時もありますけどね
たまに十五分も飛んで三十分になるかもしれませんだけど
その時は見事に最期の人々は自分の話は全部中止するんです
もうそれ以上喋れなくなりますから
では あのまあ挨拶だけで終わりにしましょうということで
もうすぐ墓場に向かいます
有名な人が死んじゃうと
もうかなり時間取りますね
代表者たちが喋るんだから
本当に馬鹿馬鹿らしいんですよ
死んだ人はどうなるかわからないし
こちらで何々代表で 会社代表でなんとかとか
あれ見栄ですね やっぱり
茶色色の褐色の色のところでお話しして青と緑を使わないっていうのは何か理由があるんですか？ 最近の人々が使う色ですから
それは青 緑 赤 黄色や純粋な色を一つも使わない
特別に青と緑を使わないということで
青 緑その二つは組み合わせでも使えないんですね
例えば黄色と赤は組み合わせちゃうと中間色が出ますけど
あれを合わせちゃうと何か仏教で着る袈裟の色が出てこないんですね
合わせることもしない
別にまあとにかくこの最期の人々が美しく見せるために使う色は使わないんです
あの さっきデーヴァダッタがその贅沢な暮らしをしてたって言ってましたけど
デーヴァダッタが贅沢な暮らしをしてたって言ってますけども
例えばその学者たちの説で
これこれこういう経典がその堕落した時の時代の話を書いてるから
後で作られた作品だとか
お釈迦様が生きてる時はそういう風なお釈迦様の目が生き届いてるから
そういう堕落した生活はしてないから
その 例えば贅沢な生活をしたり
かんとかあんなとかって言ってる話は
後で作られた経典だとかっていう説がよく書かれたりしますけど
生きてる時からデーヴァダッタそうやって贅沢な暮らしを本当にしてたんですか？それともその
お釈迦様がやめろって言ってるのに目を盗んでやってたんですか
まあ本当にどうですかと聞いちゃうとこっちが困りますよ
何て言うか 要するに  私も学者と同じ
同じく文献資料に基づいてしか喋れませんだから
ということは デーヴァダッタはお釈迦様が戒律を作って
それでお釈迦様の目が黒いうちにそれを破ってたっていうわけです
戒律破ってない そこら辺は学者の間違いでね
デーヴァダッタは戒律破ってないんです
だからみんな理解できなくたって困ってるんですけど
だらしない生活しても戒律守っていることもできます
ド派手の袈裟を着るということ自体が
色のルールから反してる
ちゃんと彼が衣を仕来りにして切って抜いて色をつけてきたんだからね
そんなアホじゃないんですよ
戒律破ってない デーヴァダッタもそのケースでも全然戒律破ってないんです
一つも だからこういう風に衣を間違っていると言ってないでしょう
やっぱり衣を着るならばそれぐらいの人格が必要ですよと言ってるだけ
戒律を破るところ 法律を犯したことだから
それは仏教では簡単に処理します
法律学もありますからね
それについてお釈迦様はほとんど立ち触りません
もう一応決まりそうだって
それはお坊さん同士で裁判までやりますしね
それはすごい簡単 だからデーヴァダッタ贅沢したと言ったっても
我々のイメージとはね
イメージ違うんです 例えば
デーヴァダッタ戒律全部なくなっちゃいましたけど
戒律は全部完全になくなりましたけどね
それもまあ難しい話ですよ
とにかくもう 彼の戒律全部なくなったのは
分裂した時なんです サンガを
サンガを分裂した同時にお釈迦様があいつはもう終わりと
もう失格になったということでね
戒律も全部もう消えちゃって
もうもう形だけの人間になっただけですね
それでも間もないうちで亡くなりましたし
この前も悪いことをしましたけど
戒律を犯してないんですよ
罪を犯してます ややこしいんです
罪を犯しているのに戒律を犯してない
サンガの分裂したところで戒律はなくなっちゃったんです
まあ贅沢といってもね
本当に贅沢したと言ったっても
我々の感覚の贅沢じゃないんですよ
出家の人々っていうのはもうかなりきつい生き方をしていたんだから
きついと言ったっても苦行したわけじゃないし
まあ食べるところと住むところと着るものについてはすごく苦労していたんですよ
だから托鉢に出ただけで食べ物を十分もらうということはもうほとんどない
これ毎日のことだからね
しかし ものすごくもう体力も使う
もう歩くは修行のために町から町へも行くし
食べるものがあってもなくても気にしないし
もう 倒れたりすることってしょっちゅうあったんだからね
お坊さんたちは 例えばお釈迦様に会って説法しますと
聞きますと思ったら 遠い遠いところから来る
来る途中で托鉢したりしなくちゃいけないしね
何日もかかることで それで托鉢できなかったんだからといって
じゃあ今日一日こちらで休んで
まあ次何か食べ物を食べて体体力つけて行くということなく
ずっと来るんですよ でお釈迦様のところに来るときに倒れるとかね
食べ物がなくて ということはまあしょっちゅうありましたから
そこでデーヴァダッタのところには
このアジャセーオが毎日そちらに住んでるお坊さんの分に食べ物を送るんです
見た目は全然贅沢でも何でもない
200人でしたと だったら 200人分ぐらい食事は来るだけのことで
しかし ブッダの弟子たちの立場から見れば
それは贅沢なんですよ
困らないんだから だから
ちょっと怠けの気持ちの人とかね
出家する時はいとも簡単にデーヴァダッタのそこら辺へたらに行っちゃうんですね
デーヴァダッタも自分にとっては何の負担もない
どうぞどうぞと 出家してくださいと
ということを言う だからデーヴァダッタも別に修行をやめない
修行を進めていた 進めていたんですよ
すごいややこしい存在なんです
彼のところに来たら もう何のことなく心広く受け止める
受け止めるだけではなくて
楽に生活もできる  1日一回ぐらいの食べ物はちゃんともらう
で 彼もじゃあ頑張ってくださいと
自分知ってるなりにいろいろ教えたりもする
しながらもう性格的にはまあ問題があったということなんです
だから最初からもうデーヴァダッタが悪人で邪道だったら出家させなきゃいいでしょうに
悪人でもなかった 邪道でもないという
もうどうにもならん状態
それはもうそこはね もう研究する人々っていうのはね
もう暇がないんだからね
研究するためにもうガタガタのことでしょうと思いますけどね
難しいんですよ その問題は
彼が怒ったのは もうお釈迦様に対してと何怒りあったわけでもないんだけど
あんまり相手にしなかったんですね
お釈迦様それは気に入らないですね
それは良くないんだと
ブッダはブッダですと
同格にはなれないんだと
もしかすると彼が家のことを考えて
同格になって何が悪いんですかと思った可能性はあります
だって自分の姉とお釈迦様が最近の時結婚していたんだから
線引きどうしてみれば同格的でしょうし
だから出家してお釈迦様はすごく有名になったら
やっぱり 2番目に自分ぐらい選んだら何が悪いんですかと
でも自分を選ばないんですね
2番目のところがいろいろ位与えたりする
それもやってないんですね
で 何々に一番第一やと位与える場合も
お釈迦様は悟ってないという与えないんです
アナンダ尊者以外は 悟ってる人々にはこの人は説法第一とかね
この人は何々かの第一とかね
80人ぐらい位ね 与えてやったんですけど
デーヴァダッタは何もない
悟ってもないし こういう風なすごい個人的なことは絡んだんじゃないかなと
それで彼のところにお坊さんたちも来るし
彼がもう一応自分をリーダーとして認めてくださいと
それ頼むんですよ もう待っていて
待っていて これ一向に自分の存在を認めるはずが
認めるわけじゃないお釈迦様
それで行って まあお釈迦様は忙しいし
お釈迦様はお釈迦様のなりの立場でいればいいんじゃないかと
こういうつまらないことにまで手を出したりしてはなくて
私は比丘たちの管理人として
別にお釈迦様と同じレベルということも頼んでないんですよ
お釈迦様は釈尊でブッダでいて
弟子たちの管理役ぐらいは私がやってあげますと
だから怒られるんですよ
出家の管理人は認めませんと
リーダーを このサーリプッタ
たとえとして使った たとえこのサーリプッタであろうと
モクレン尊者であろうと
私はリーダーとしては見てませんよ
お前みたいな人に選ぶとき
君知ってますか？選べられとるということを言ったんで
それはすごい気に障っちゃったんです
その時もそこは釈迦様が嫌みったのは
この吐いてるものを食べてるんだと
それですごくもう気に障ってしまったんです
お釈迦様の言葉が 吐いてるものを食べて食べてるって言ったって
彼だけまとめのご飯食べてたんです
でも彼 お釈迦様はそれを吐いてるものを食べてるんだと
いわゆる仏教で認めてない方法でご飯を食べてるんです
これでまあだったら暴動を起こして自分で別れるしかないんだと
言って暴動を起こしちゃったんです
それが分裂ですね それでその人の終わったと
そこまでお釈迦様はなんとかもうおとなしくなってくれればという気持ちはあったでしょう
あまりにも叱られるといくらか落ち着くでしょうとかね
しかし 分裂暴動を起こしてた時点からはもう救うことはできません
ということで 贅沢贅沢と言ったってもね
なんかわからないんですよ
ただ托鉢しないで楽にご飯食べてたぐらいかな
そこを見ると テーラワーダのお坊さんたちが私でもびっくりするほど贅沢してるんですよ
私はできるだけ逃げて逃げているのは贅沢嫌だからなんです
ものすごいみんな贅沢と言えるかどうか分かりませんが
楽で生きてるんですね
これという問題はないんだからね
日本にいるんですけど
私食べられなくなった日っていうのはどれぐらいあると知ってますかね
日本は食べ物ないわけでもないしね
いろいろまあ しかし寺にいるとね
そんなのはしきたり儀式で決まってるんだからね
だからまあ それは外食の基準でまあめんどくさい話でね
お釈迦様の時代よりは今の坊さんたちは楽に生きてます
一番わかりやすいのは衣なんですね
昔 衣一つっていうのはもう一生一枚あればありがたいぐらいの
珍しいもので 今はもう嫌というほどあるんだから
戒律守れません 今の状態で
だって一着しか持ってはいけないんですよ
一着のところか もうもう私は
私も 私は一番もらわない立場
なのに これどう処分すればいいかと
この前行く時でもいくつか持っていったんです
スリランカへ 誰かにあげようと
それだけでカバンが重くなっちゃっても困るし
子供たちに他の小遣いのおもちゃとかなんか買ってあげて
なのにこれ衣一着で重いしね
だからもうもらわない場合は私は第一やと思いますけど
そういう私にも結構あるんです
衣 だから昔と比べるとどれほど変わってるかと
それでも私はボロボロになるまで洗って洗って着ますけど
他のミャンマーのお坊さんやらタイのお坊さん見るとみんなピンピンな衣いつでも着ています
ピカピカの新しいもの
だからどうするんですかね
あれはもう捨てるんでしょうか
1週間で新しいものに入れ替えるかどうかわかりません
私がもらうものはもう誰か誰かに回しちゃいます
であげますけど だから今の時代っていうのはそういう時代だからね
だから戒律さえも戒律では衣に際して決まってるものは保管してはいけない
もらったら余分にもらったら
個人でもらっても 使うならばなんか 1週間 10 日間ぐらい日にちが時間制限があります
時間制限切れ取る前に処分しなくちゃいけないんです
だから処分と言ったっても
サンガのものにするしか処分方法ない
それを処分しなかったら
自動的に自分のものでなくなってるんです
オートモードで保管しておくこと
で それでサンガのもの
自分が鍵をかけてあったっても
それだけじゃなくて 処分しなかったという訴えもかかってくる
今のお坊さんとは全然それはもう全くもう守れないんです
衣ありすぎて  現実にはお寺の倉庫の中
鍵のかかってない倉庫に置いておく以外方法は無いと
うん まあそうしたってもね
まあそういう余裕があるお寺だったらね
まあそうやってもらったものはそのままその場で手放ししてね
別に置いとくことはできますけどね
それはそういう意味もないよ
大体自分の部屋で置いておくということになるし
難しいね そういうところ
現代社会で戒律を守ろうと思うと
かえって一般の人々には大変苦しいんです
例えば今 食べ物やらいろんなものがあるんだから
みんなお寺に持ってくる
米やら野菜やら何から何までとかね
そうするとお坊さんちは触ったり使ったり管理してはいけないと
そうすると 在家の人々が別に職業としてそういうことをやらなくちゃいけない
結局 お寺というのはえらい巨大な組織に
事情的になってしまうんですね
お金の管理する経理係やら
食べ物の管理する人やら
これお寺ですかと また逆に
行きたくなっちゃうし
だから社会変わるとそこら辺はもう生活世界だからね
仏教ですね だからそこら辺お釈迦様もそんなに気にしてないんです
それは変わると知っているしね
知ってて そこら辺はいろいろ
それは問題ではありませんようにという風になっているんです
豪華な衣を着るなかれと言っても
自分住んでいる街でみんな豪華な服しか着ないんだったら
村人は嫌なんですよ ボロボロ服が着ているお坊さんを頭下げて礼をしたり
説法したりするの だから豪華なものを着させたりする
それは認める それからみんな清潔で履物を履いて足を綺麗にしている場合は
私は裸足でいるんだぞと
裸足でいると もう西域の人々はもう裸足で泥やらいろんなものを踏んだりして家に入るのは嫌がる可能性はいくらでもあります
そこで西域の人はもうそれお願いしますから
ちゃんとした草履履いてくださいって言ったら履くんです
そういうところはまあ柔軟性をおいてあります
決して柔軟性をおいてない戒律もあります
それは心に直接関するものなので
わけもわからない話をあおりましょう
まあ仏教堕落してから後で作った話っていうか分かりません
とにかくもう戒律の中にも大乗のことが出てくるわ
経典の中でも出てくるし
だからそこら辺は仏典というか文献としては古いでしょうしね
だから誰かの好き勝手で
そこからも全部後の話やというのはね
それはそんなに学術的でもないんです
自分の意見をなんとか正当化をするためにもう史実をごまかすっていうことですから
その場合はね うまくいかなかったことは確かなんです
この二人は お釈迦様が大乗だった
それで彼が自分をお釈迦様に一つ一本
お釈迦様から一本取られたという状態になったのは
あの五つの戒律でしょ
彼が五つの戒律を決めたんでしょうし
それにお釈迦様は真っ向から反対するんですね
ある面でお釈迦様はやられちゃったんですよ
なぜならば 表面的には立派そうな戒律なんですね
で 表面的な立派であろうが
中身が立派であろうが
人が決めた戒律は いかなる理由でも如来として
ブッダとして認めるわけにはいきません
戒律はブッダが決めるんです
悟った人が決めるんです
人にその権利もないんです
たとえ人が人を殺してはいけません
ですから お釈迦様も人を殺してはいけませんと戒律作ってくださいと言ったら断ります
人の話聞かないんですよ
真理もわからない 無知の中にいる
暗闇の中 ですから 生まれつき目が見えない人から色のアドバイス受けますかね
生まれつき目がない人からちょっとこのどんな色でいいでしょうかねとかね
聞かんでしょうに だからブッダは人の話は聞かないのはそういうわけなんです
だから戒律設定するのはお釈迦様たった一人
それには我々には反論する権利もない
それで女性 の出家の場合
私に説明されちゃってね
私はそんな権利はありませんよと
ったところで これものすごい誤解して私に怒ってかかってくるんですけどね
怒ってかかってくると
こちらも親切じゃないんだからね
それで私はまあ 出家の場合はという場合は
法律出家は戒律であることで
出家ということも戒律行事でしょ
戒律行事は戒律に則ってやらなくちゃいけないし
それでこの平等論を語るもう愚か者たちがもうそのために戒律行事を変えてくださいと
戒律行事を我々には変えられませんだから
これはもう絶対的なお釈迦様だけのことだから
であんた方は頑固ではないかと
頑固ですかね 自分に権利ないものをやることが
アホでしょうに 私は勝手に日本憲法変えたって
もう日本憲法変えたことになりますかね
よくしゃべることそういうことを
私にできないことはできない
権利がないことは権利がない
それははっきり私もたくさんの女の人が出家した方がすごくありがたいことだと
今バランスが崩れているんだと
個人でそれはありがたいと思っても
自分では憲法を変えられません
でも一つ穴がありますよ
法律から抜ける それは誰にも見つからないところ
面白いんです タイとかどこかでの女の人を出家させてる組織もあります
それ法律違反ですよ 法律違反です
そういう連中も偉そうに戒律云々と言うんですけど
この抜け穴があることはわからないんですね
だから戒律もわかってないだけ
ちゃんと抜け穴があるんです
お釈迦様が作って そういうどういう抜け穴かというと
人が男であろうが女であろうが
子供であろうが 修行して悟り開く
それが仏道の目的なんですよ
目的に達した人は偉いのは決まってるでしょうに
その人はまた修行します
だから出家させてくれと頼むことはもう関係ないんです
もう修行を卒業してるんです
だから 五 六人くらい女の人々が悟ってしまえば
もうそれで仏道完成したんだから
もう資格取ってるんですよ
戒律という人間のために作った決まりではなくて
真理の礼儀で だから そういう人々が現れてきてね
じゃあもう弟子を入れて君たち出家しなさいと言っても
それは大丈夫です その場合
正式的な出家にする場合はまた戒律に戻りますけど
その人々はオートモードで出家だから
無条件でオートモードで
お坊さんたちには何も言う権利はない
悟っている人に対しては
何か言うんじゃなくて教えてもらうことになるんだから
だったらそれ頑張ればいいでしょうに
そうじゃなくて 私も精神証明のアマさんだよとかいう俗的な威張るためにだったら出家しない方がいいんですよ
とにかくそうやってな
何て言いますかね 私たちには権利がないという一言にかなり怒られたんですね
それはただもう男たちだけの自分の立場を守るために言ってるいいわけではないかと
私に男女平等ですかと聞いたっても答えられませんだからね
俺に聞くなよと どうしても質問自体がおかしくなると
私はもう決まって相手を怒らせます
これはもう自分の決まってる人格ではなくて性格なんですね
怒らせます 質問が間違っても知りたい気持ちあると
先生の気分で質問を直してあげて説明します
質問が正しければすばり答える
延々としゃべりません
これすごい時間かかったのは質問が正しくないんですよ
質問の構成は ガタガタです
しかし 知りたいことを聞いてるんだから
もう延々と答えもガタガタになるんです
もし知りたい気持ちなかったならば一言葉で答えますけど
かなり怒ると思います
そういうことで終了します